yesterday cbs put out a interview with
uh treasury secretary janet yellen uh
for those that don't know the irs has
put forward a proposal and what they
want to do is they want any bank account
that has 600 or more in it they want to
know what's going on they want to be
able to get their little prying eyes on
yo cash if you got more than 600 in an
account they want to know deposits end
withdrawals or payments what is going on
they are asking financial institutions
banks and credit unions to go ahead and
do it here we got janet yellen peeking
in your piggy bank there we go and so
when she was asked about this yesterday
here is what she said on cbs evening
news you want banks to report
transactions of six hundred dollars or
more that's what the irs wants
does this mean that the government is
trying to peek into our pocketbooks if
you want to look at 600 transactions
absolutely not i think this proposal has
been seriously
mischaracterized
the proposal
involves no reporting of individual
transactions of any individual look the
big picture is that we have a tax gap
that over the next decade is estimated
at seven trillion dollars namely a
shortfall in the amount that irs is
collecting
due to
a failure
of individuals to report the income that
they've earned but that's among
billionaires is that among people who
are transferring six hundred dollars no
it tends to be among high income
individuals whose income is opaque and
the irs doesn't receive information
about it if you earn a paycheck you get
a w-2 the irs knows about it but
high-income individuals with opaque
sources of income that are not reported
to the irs there's a lot of tax fraud
and cheating that's going on and all
that's involved in this proposal is a
few aggregate numbers about bank
accounts the amount that was received in
the course of a year the amount that
went out in the course of the year if
somebody reports an income of ten
thousand dollars and they had three
million dollars
go out of their checking account that
tells the irs that's a that's an
individual you might audit i mean the
white house says that american
billionaires pay an average income tax
rate of
8.2 percent yes it's extremely low
that's lower than teachers then cops
then a lot of people it's unfair
and it's something that we need to
remedy
all right
all right there's a lot to unpack here
first i'm gonna start with the facts
americans did not pay eight percent
tax rates the wealthiest americans did
not pay eight percent that is absolutely
propaganda talking point from the white
house the white house put out a report
if you remember we broke down the report
the report said if the rules said that
we were going to tax unrealized gains
then and only then would their tax rates
be 8.2 that's not what the rules are and
that's not what people paid go look at
their tax records many times they've
been leaked you can go see they paid
much much higher rates than eight
percent that is literally misinformation
we just listened to misinformation
second of all is the fact that i don't
know a single time in history anyone has
reported ten thousand dollars in income
and they were sending three million
dollars out of their bank account that
is an egregious absurd example at what
point i would like to see one example in
history where somebody reported only ten
thousand dollars of income but they
really had three million dollars of
income i don't believe it third of all
is that if there's a seven trillion
dollar tax gap
there are 330 million americans that
would be equivalent to each american
being responsible for twenty one
thousand two hundred and twelve dollars
each
to make up that seven trillion dollar
gap now they are saying that it is not
everybody it is only the wealthiest
people there are 2
700 billionaires in the entire world if
you think it's them
go and do something with them
why do you need to know the person who
has a thousand dollars in their bank
account what they're doing
let's say that they actually cheated
jada 50 bucks
they were really bad people very
nefarious actually very dangerous
actually some may say
is it really worth doing this and giving
up the freedom because you think
somebody might have cheated you on 50
bucks again it's absurd to think that
now i do understand the point that they
are not saying we are going to see every
single transaction we instead are going
to just see how much came in how much
went out but here is the problem that's
what they're saying today tomorrow
they'll say oh now that we know how much
is coming in we actually need an
itemized record of how much of that
where is that all coming from who sent
you that money oh we see a lot of money
went out of your account where is that
going how much is it actually going out
at what time so the slippery slope
continues and so ultimately what we're
watching is we're watching financial
surveillance and financial surveillance
is not what america was built on instead
what we should be talking about is the
fact that we need financial privacy we
should be encouraging more and more and
more americans to actually have the
privacy if you think about american
ideals and american ethos what you
remember is that it is not worth
encroaching on any one single
individual's rights to try to go after
anybody that you might think is bad i
understand your job may be harder i'm
not saying that anyone at the irs or the
treasury federal reserve politicians etc
have an easy job but it is their job and
so when you start to think about this
why are we encroaching on the freedoms
of one individual in order to try to
catch a couple of billionaires that you
think might not be paying their full
taxes plano what do you think um i have
two thoughts on this one i don't trust
anybody who answers a question that's
yes or no with absolutely not
that's just i don't know um two
uh
i recently overheard a call where
somebody was asking anthony for some
financial information that the other
person clearly did not need um and
they're like well if it's easy for you
to pull it why don't you just send it to
me and anthony goes because i value my
financial privacy i did say that to that
guy
i put that guy in a locker actually good
i hope he watches this too
yeah i gave him a swirly a virtual swirl
no problem
virtual swords
somebody somebody was like uh was trying
to get me to give him all this
information and i said i'm not going to
do that he was like wow you have to and
i said no i don't he said you have to no
i don't and we went back and forth for a
little bit and then he turns out he's
not happy he says it's easy to pull and
i said oh okay so what and uh yeah of
course eventually i didn't have to give
him financial
eyes away from my bread this is a
stepping stone
to
giving up privacy in your financial life
if there is a gap in if there's a gap in
what people are reporting as income and
they want to go after the billionaires
and the successful people in life
they're not doing it over six hundred
dollars that should not be the minimum
what do you what do we think the uh
threshold should be should it be people
with a million dollars in a bank account
should be people with two hundred fifty
thousand i don't think it's an issue
should it be based on a transaction or
the value that you hold in your bank
account i think it should be based on a
transaction if you really want to do it
that way i don't think it necessarily
has to be a million but it's definitely
not 600 i think that they actually
shouldn't do it at all yeah i was just
going to say i don't think there's
anyone but i don't
like i don't care if you got 20 million
dollars in your bank account they
shouldn't have the ability to see how
much is going in and out unless they got
a warrant
well unless unless
you want to see the information go get
award because you must think i'm doing
something wrong but if you don't think
i'm doing something wrong why do you
need the information yep but right
unless unless the irs is like hey like
this is very suspicious whatever i agree
um but my my question is i she didn't
answer the question of like why is this
necessary she kept talking about the
wealthiest people but 600 in your
account does not qualify you as one of
the wealthiest people well to be clear
and i see somebody in the comments it's
like oh you guys are just protecting
billionaires no no no just so we're very
clear this is the way that this works is
what they do is they basically say hey
the big bad billionaires the rich people
the wealthy the successful people you're
not like them you don't have a billion
dollars you're not wealthy you're not
successful let's we're gonna try to get
them but then they write the rules in a
way that encroaches on your freedom as
well and so do not be tricked this has
nothing to do with i don't give a [ __ ]
about billionaires right what i care
about is that this is an encroachment on
the financial privacy that every single
person should have the right to because
i saw somebody else say it in america
you were innocent until proven guilty
this is the opposite this says
everyone's guilty until they're proven
innocent
you don't need the information and so
somebody like a senator lummus in
wyoming absolutely took the treasury
secretary to task earlier saying why do
you need to know when the cattle
ranchers buy a new cattle and she said
why do you need to know somebody wants
to buy a new couch
why do you need to know if you think
that they're doing something wrong there
is an avenue to go figure that out but
ultimately what we're finding is that
it's not that they think everyone's
doing something wrong this is just an
encroachment on that financial privacy
on top of it i can think of two
different billionaires or three
different billionaires actually in the
last 12 months
that have gotten themselves in trouble
and had to pay massive uh settlements so
robert smith
from uh what was it about uh vista
equity partners yeah his uh partner or
whatever uh uh brockman right uh robert
brockman and then the third is uh all
the guys at uh renaissance technology
they just had a massive set of i think
they had to pay a couple billion dollars
uh as well and these aren't people who
necessarily were doing something that
was like super nefarious it always comes
down to like hey we thought that we were
paying the right taxes we had a letter
from a lawyer whatever right whether
that's nefarious or not is up for for
debate but
if they're able to catch catch and i put
that in their quotes those people and
they had to pay fines or had to pay some
of the taxes it sounds like the existing
system we have is working like you're
finding out the people who are doing
things wrong why do you need to know
what somebody has six hundred dollars in
their bank account like there's
literally going to be 16 year olds who
work a summer job they get 600 in the
bank account and the government
hey let me see what's going on in there
in in what's up
and actually if the government cared
that much about billionaires doing
nefarious things
robert smith would have gotten a much
much heavier handed uh
penalty than he did
therefore i don't think it's about
wealthy people at all